what we are experiencing are the
inevitable consequences of digital
technology i'm afraid that capitalism is
not sustainable i want to hear the
bankers and others saying that's got to
be reformed i want to bring meaning back
into the study of economics what does
that it mean for changing how we relate
to one another
[Music]
i should think what what do economists
mean when they say capitalism and the
answer is
economists don't say capitalism we don't
use that word really as and um and i
think there's a reason which is that
what people
seem to mean when they talk about
capitalism is three
not necessarily uh connected things
there's some association between them
but they're not the same thing
uh one of them is markets relying on
on decentralized we're relying on on
prices to tell people what to produce
what to do
as opposed to uh telling them what to do
um the second is the notion that your
individual
standard of living your pursing power is
uh is determined by
what you can sell yourself or what you
own on the market
and the third is that the
big determinant of how much you have of
how how rich you are if you like is how
much
in the way of assets you own so that
there's there are these three things
market economies
uh market incomes as being
basically what income is is about and
the third is is capital in the sense of
that that the that that being a
capitalist is how you are a person of uh
exceptional uh wealth and and status and
power
and the thing is in all three respects
we only
sort of kind of partially live under
capitalism in any of those senses
so if you ask about markets and this is
something where i'm just as
one of the funny things about market
fundamentalists
is that they
their image of the the economy we live
in tends to be one in which it's all
individuals freely contracting with each
other and good god i mean uh the that's
that's not the way most people live
um and the last bit about capital i mean
how do we
where does let's say private equity
managers
fit into the the notion of capitalism as
being who owns the capital
because those are you know they they
they are certainly very wealthy and very
powerful powerful enough to buy
themselves in the united states a
extraordinary tax privilege um it's not
based on what they own exactly uh
they're
allegedly managing other people's money
uh and yet they are
well that favorite statistic is that the
25 top
equity managers earn about three times
as much as uh as the uh
250 000 school teachers in new york um
so it's it's quite a uh a lot of um
i'm sorry it's 80 000 school teachers
i'm i'm merging my anyway you get the
picture it's enormously concentration
which is not exactly capitalism even
pickety
um concedes i mean not concedes he knows
it and um for for the united states for
the anglo-saxon countries britain as
well the um
the vast increase in inequality so far
has been mostly about
about compensation
it has been about fees and and bonuses
and and not
about capital income capital income is
growing and that there's a very powerful
argument in piketty's book that it will
continue to grow that we are on our way
to becoming a patrimonial society but we
are not now at the moment we're not that
kind of thing so um
i i think that actually in some ways the
the
phrasing this in terms of capitalism is
the way we're going to put it the
question is could we have something that
is substantially different from what we
do now should we
and my answer is
sort of
[Music]
we've got today is a system of rentia
capitalism where all the economic rules
that i learned as a student at cambridge
have broken down
it used to be the case that the share of
national income going to capital and the
share going to labor were roughly
constant over time
but across the world in country after
country including china in the united
states and most other countries the
share going to capital has gone up the
share going to labor has gone down but
more importantly than that the share
going to the renters
the people who have property and assets
financial physical or intellectual has
been shooting up
let me give you one or two key
statistics which indicate a system in
crisis
it used to be the case that private
wealth in this country
in the nineteen seventies was worth
about three hundred percent of gdp
today
private wealth
is seven hundred percent or nearly seven
hundred percent of gdp
and the inequality of wealth
far exceeds the inequality of earned
income
if you look further at the wealth
statistics you very quickly identify the
fact that over 60 percent of total
wealth in this country is inherited
wealth
in other words it's not been earned by
production or employment
or brilliance it's inherited
and you can see the same sort of
phenomenon all over the world it's not
quite the piketty story
but then you see the breakdown of simple
basic economics
that we were taught at university
and it used to be the case that when
productivity went up
wages went up
not anymore
it's called the opening of the jaws of
the snake
so when profits have gone up or
productivity have gone up average wages
have tended to fall
real wages in france in germany in the
united states have been static
and falling for the precariat the group
that i've been writing about for the
last 30 years
this is a system in systemic crisis
and this is why our politics are also in
crisis because the basic economics that
we were taught if you work hard
your incomes will go up that's not the
case anymore millions of people work
damn hard
and they're not making anything worthy
of
a decent life
[Music]
pandemic is a global phenomena those
nasty viruses don't carry passports and
visas and if
you are sicker it's more likely that
more of your popular if you're not as
healthy because you're poorer more of
your population will come down with the
disease and that will be a vector for
spreading the disease around the world
migration is a problem that europe has
faced migration pressure will increase
the greater the divide between the rich
and the poor
so there are so many aspects of our
well-being in the advanced countries
uh
that are interdependent
with what is going on in the developing
and emerging markets and in countries
outside our borders
uh that we have to think about this from
a global uh perspective i wanted to
comment on one particular aspect of this
that's why we have to have global rules
that serve the interest of the whole
world
and uh one part of that problem is that
a lot of those rules
have been written not to serve
our interests in the developed countries
or the interests of the developing
countries they've been
designed to serve corporate interests
uh
in the united states and europe
but not interest of ordinary people of
workers uh
or of the developing countries so
there's go back to the
theme i talked about a lot of
exploitation
so
part of the problem is that what has
been going on
has been that
corporate interests have taken advantage
of
emerging markets developing countries
but not in ways that advantage the
citizens in general in our countries but
just advantage themselves
and that's uh lisa referred to to uh uh
the depth track diplomacy of china and
it's clearly true but it's also true in
the advanced countries
uh we have not done
uh what uh we should do to discourage
that excessive lending to poor countries
with uh outrageous conditions
and one aspect of that's very important
in 2015
the united nations
uh
set forth a set of principles for debt
restructuring a lot of countries get
over-indebted
sometimes because they were encouraged
to get more debt
um and when you face that excess of debt
domestically we have bankruptcy courts
this set of principles internationally
we don't have that
overwhelmingly the country around the
world
voted a set of principles for debt for
for sovereign debt restructuring
there were just a couple countries six
countries that voted against
the united states was one
i think uk was another
um and i hope that changes uh because
of the lack of a mechanism for
restructuring this debt
uh a lot of countries from around the
world are suffering
and the absence of that
allows the financial sector to exercise
enormous amount of power squeeze rent
the poorest countries
and that encourages them not to do the
due diligence and to lend excessively
so
it really is we don't we can see it on
the part of china as it engages in that
diplomacy but it's very much a part of
the united states in the uk
[Music]
think about the word capitalism it was
invented actually by the enemies of the
19th century
liberals
oh that's not a
that's not anywhere near a decisive
argument
but it focuses on capital accumulation
as the way that we get better off
and up really until the late
1950s and gradually over the decades
after that
most economists believe that
adam smith the blessed adam smith cross
myself
believed that
the highlands of scotland if they would
just behave themselves
could become as rich as the dutch which
was his model of
a a
high-income society
if they would just save and accumulate
and that's all you needed
and this was
this was translated into marxism for
example
and then in in conventional bourgeois
economics up as i say up until
uh
50 years ago 70 or yeah about 50 years
ago economists believed this
and it was the the doctrine for example
at the world bank
that the way to make ghana rich
is to
put lots of
foreign aid into ghana and not one cent
into red china for example
and then ghana would be prosperous
and red china would stay poor
well you may have noticed that that
didn't happen
so
sheer capital accumulation without
innovation
without new ideas coming from the minds
of free people from non-slaves
is just
piling up if you own an auto
how would you be a lot better off if you
had six autos
of course not
um if you have an apartment would it be
nice to have 12 apartments no
sheer capital accumulation doesn't pay
off it to express it as john maynard
keynes did in 1936
the marginal efficiency of investment
could be driven down to zero
in a generation which is to say
that sheer
piling up
of what we all agree are good things
like factories and roads and schools and
so forth
sheer piling up
doesn't do the trick that's not what
made us rich and boy did we become rich
from innovation
three
thousand percent better off than in
eighteen hundred now this this is people
find this number hard to believe but
it's
the ask any economic historian and
they'll say yep that's about it
three thousand percent better off not
a hundred percent or two hundred percent
but three thousand percent
and that came from innovation
so what we'd better call this system we
have
is not capitalism
people are terminally confused about
this capitalism has always existed there
have always been middlemen and factories
there were factories for making uh
fish sauce and rum
there are factories to make
silk cloth in china from ancient times
no
it's innovation that was peculiar
[Music]
google discovered
what may be the last virgin would
and that turns out to be our private
experience
google claimed our private experience as
free raw material to be translated into
behavioral
data these data would be collected from
every domain it began online as you all
know
but it now reaches far beyond online
who's got an alexa in their kitchen
who's got a tv that listens
who's walking down the street not only
passing the cctv cameras
which are public sector
but the tech companies have fought for
the right to be able to take our faces
from any public space without our ever
knowing forget about consent forget
about the right to combat
so now these data are being amassed
they are valued for their rich
predictive signals
they are
shunted into complex supply chains of
data flows
they are conveyed picture those
old-fashioned conveyor belts conveying
them right into a factory but what is
this factory it's a computational
factory it's called ai
artificial intelligence but like any
factory it makes products
in this case it makes prediction
products
what's computed
are predictions of our behavior
turns out there are a lot of businesses
who have a keen interest in knowing what
we will do soon and later
first to sell is targeted ads but it
doesn't stop there
there are all kinds of reasons to know
what we will do in the future
what price to sell us their service or
their product
whether or not to give us an insurance
policy and at what level of cost
whether or not to give us a mortgage or
a bank loan there are lots and lots of
reasons they want to be able to predict
our behavior how are we going to drive
that you know that can influence what
our auto insurance look like
there are many many issues and they they
arise in every single economic sector
[Music]
part of my thesis is that from 2009
onwards
the role that prophets used to play
in fueling the engine that pulled
capitalism ahead
was
profits were replaced by central bank
money
you can see that
most of the important the most important
companies over the last 10 15 years
don't really make profits
if you look at uber
airbnb netflix spotify
tesla
very little profits if any if any
what drives them is a stock exchange
where their shares are going through the
roof and why are the shares going
through the roof because central banks
have been printing the money to make
sure that the financial markets remain
in rude health the second pillar markets
they are on the way out and i've already
explained why
because command capital has risen
to such an extent
that not only does it tell us what we
want but it also creates the
platforms on which we can actually buy
that which they tell us that we want
and remember these are not markets
they're platforms the moment you enter
amazon.com you have exited capitalism
in the same way that the moment you walk
into the
the google campus in california um next
capitalism because you enter a centrally
planned organization with a complete
hierarchy there's no market in google in
the same way there is no market in
general models there is no market in
volkswagen the moment you enter the
factory there's no market there it's
like you know
a stalinist organization maybe it's
quite pleasant but it's still a
hierarchical top-down non-market
organization
the moment you enter amazon.com remember
there is one person that owns the
algorithm that determines once you're in
amazon.com what you see what you
you know what you can buy what you can't
buy what you can't see some people see
one thing other people see another thing
it's this algorithm that determines that
this is not a market this is like
a few dollar state a fifth
only it's
a digital one a digital system what we
have is a new kind of capital which i
call command capital
that
has
given rise to a new
ruling class the cloudy lists
with
traditional capitalists
becoming subsumed becoming
a vassal class
vis-a-vis
the cloudy lists you have the
replacement of profit making
with central bank money which creates
new ways of telling people what you do
what to do
because if you are elon musk for
instance
uh your capacity to make the world go
round
draws from the value of your shares of
the shares of tesla spacex and so on and
the the the those values are not that
much related to profit at all they're
related to
the
um state money the central banks are
printing
as well as to the command capital
[Music]
we were just talking about a friend of
mine francesca bria who's one of a
visiting scholars at the institute i run
at ucl she was the chief digital officer
in barcelona for the mayor ala collao
and they really i think did a very
interesting uh think about this whole
kind of value generation with the tech
companies because if you don't again
focus on where is value coming from and
you just are constantly catching up with
the problems that might arise from this
distorted notion of who the wealth
creators are then the state in this case
the city will always just be kind of
coming to the problem afterwards oh we
have to tax the company oh my god
privacy just kind of always catching up
with the situation
um and what they did in barcelona was or
batson like you say at the italian
barcelona barcelona uh was to say why
don't we start thinking about building
like a public repository where every
time you click on say citymapper the
data that's generated because data isn't
static is generated through activity
actually goes back to a publicly
governed repository which then has
direct effects direct benefits to public
transport for example right so and if
companies want access to this data which
we as cities are generating through
uh our use of apps to get around the
city then they might have to either pay
into it or sign up to certain types of
conditions but anyway just really
instead of just catching up with the
problem rethinking the value proposition
itself of how to set up a more symbiotic
system
um so what to do first of all this is
not about saying where is value created
versus where is it extracted it just
means really bringing back that notion
to the center and not saying things like
you know finance is terrible but how can
we fundamentally radically reform the
way that the financial sector operates
in order to steer it bring it back into
what the classicals used to call the
production boundary and this could be
through really obvious things that you
know it's really not rocket science but
things like the um
financial transaction tax right to make
it uh less profitable to do millisecond
trades versus long-run trades that was
put forth after the financial crisis and
has not been adopted widely it could
also be about setting up new types of
institutions mutuals cooperatives public
banks themselves which are more
long-termist and actually provide
capital development for the economy
itself instead of the way that finance
has recently just kind of been financing
itself but it really does i think in
essence require us to go back and ask
what does it mean to talk about value as
collectively produced because this is in
fact what's happening now this notion of
stakeholder value has come back
as the concept of shareholder value is
being talked about even in places like
davos as a problem we all of a sudden
talk again about stakeholder value which
means that you worry about all the
different actors you know in the system
that need to also be invested in and if
you read that letter or even larry
fink's letter i think in 2008 the head
of blackrock also said that but that's
going to be impossible to do unless we
go back to first principles and really
rethink both the accounting systems
things like gdp but also what is the
underlying notion of where this value
was created in the first place as
opposed to just thinking oh we'll do
some handouts to the communities or yes
we'll pay our workers a bit more if we
don't actually believe that workers or
the state or different types of
organizations also in civil society are
active co-creators of value it's just
not going to happen
[Music]
cryptocurrencies and so on and i will
definitely add
i love them
in a terrified way the wall street bats
and all that stuff you know these are
signs of a gradual disintegration of
capitalism as we know it
and as always i'm here marxist
pessimist with elements of optimism it's
an open situation that's why i don't
think we are in a medical emergency
we should now forget about politics we
live now in perhaps a most politicized
moment in our lives more than 68 things
are really changing look at germany also
now at this moment of course with all
the counter-attacks it will probably
lose some points the strongest part in
germany is the green party and the right
wingers are already basically openly
saying better alternative for germany
their ecosocial is there the greatest
danger and so on and so on it's
incredible what is happening and my hope
is this one we have
the populist new populist new right and
new corporate neofelder whatever
capitalism and
we should appeal to
liberals and tell them you are losing
the only way liberalism can be saved in
the sense of
redeeming
what is worth fighting for human
freedoms blah blah all the things that
we like is to make a leftward spin you
know to move to the left
they are
because in some paradoxical sense you
remember how
both donald trump and his european
version victor orban from hungary
draw a totally new political mapping for
them for
says i love this passage he said
there are no liberals there it's only us
right-wing populist and communist
liberals are just his expression
communists with a diploma you know
trump said the same he said biden kamala
harris these are socialists communists
and so on and my
bet is that in some sense they are
partially right
it's crazy to say by me the communities
but
we should strategically support what
some of the measures of what briden and
kamala harris are doing now why
not as old communists who say anyway but
we have a secret plot to take over but
we should just catch them by their work
how do you put it you know like if you
really mean what you are doing
you will be obliged to make further step
and further steps in the future and so
on and so on we live again in a quite
unique moment where on the one can the
danger is this short-term pragmatism
yeah that's all we can do
but the danger is also fake radicalism
which
means something that i like to call a
radical principled opportunism you know
in a situation where you can
through
strategic support of some even existing
measure you can gain points you say no
no this is not yet the true revolution
let's wait
it's a principal position which is very
comfortable because this means
let me sit back in my academic
clearance let's wait no now it's not the
time to wait
[Music]